welcome to this video playing max power
from
Denmark okay let's do something else not
my
usual BOGO nimzo stuff okay now he
playing this kind of stuff that's not
really exciting as
well ah okay so sort of yeah this is
like some
um something that resembles the
fianchetto variation against the the pck
defense but with the Knight on
F3 yeah that's not very
exciting but of course very
um very solid for white can I do B6
Bishop
B7 he might have D5 now okay but he does
not does not go for
it okay so h i wants to go Queen D6 yeah
using
the the the weakened um C6
Pawn that's oh that's a bit
ugly that's really a bit
ugly Knight
takes Knight takes Queen
D6 n that's also not
good wow that's that's really really
really really
annoying
check what am I doing here with this can
I go King
E7 Rook takes Bishop C7 no not
really Bishop B7 yeah Rook D1 Rook E7
maybe ah it looks it looks really H look
it does not look
good that B6 move I should
have maybe considered a bit more
carefully okay so he tries to get in
this this bishop um
H3 uh move
quickly um King
E7 King E7
Rook
D1 E5 is also always always
hanging
yeah cannot I cannot move uh the
Rooks Rook C8 Rook C7 and
then
huh
yeah I know it looks like it looks bad
but I don't see don't see a
move
H this is potentially not as bad as it
looks which is probably nothing special
because it looks bad but
um sometimes times um this this this
type of situation isn't really that
clear I have decent uh activity with
this
Knight Bishop F1 is a move though
H um
okay I wonder if I should let him
take or capture capture myself I
probably should take myself he's got
Knight
C4
coming that looks that looks passive
right but I don't know I need to do it
anyway I guess and now maybe I can go
for B5 the right
moment uh okay Knight to
B4
yeah okay Knight B4 does not make much
sense yeah if he can play
C3 so just
back can I can I get in B5
maybe B5 would be helpful Rook A1 is
maybe a
move maybe I should prepare B5
trying for some sort of
activity
Maybe
now I'm threatening B5 definitely he
will go Knight C2 Knight two to C4 I
guess and then I have to move the Knight
back it's really not much
fun yeah I got I got myself in trouble
with this careless B6
move what is he thinking about Knight
two to C4 is quite
clear
okay now B5 why not I don't see it I can
he can take of course of course so I I
need to go
back again intending
B5 yeah I cannot I cannot I cannot uh in
any way play for a win here I mean
absolutely
not draw offer that's very meek for
white to do that
but white is still just uh just much
much better what he needs to do is to
just do this of course and and then I'm
I'm still in bed shape after Knight B7 I
cannot do this very passive and if I
trade I still can never play B5 because
A5 hangs and I'm totally tied to those
two pawns this is
um this is really strategically speaking
um an awful very awful situation the
problem is that this B6 move was
exceptionally
careless if we go
back here B6 is really not a good idea
even even the computer is not really
mind it that
much but uh it's not looking good it
wants to take with the Rook
however was still thinking that this
does not really okay Rook A7 is a good
reply okay I didn't see that one yeah
this this is a bit yeah this is
important now because I don't um invite
his Rook into D6 so quickly and if he
decides to take my Rook is doing a good
job of Defending C6 and D7 yeah okay
okay then it's not that bad what I did
this B6 at least but check here uh it's
really really
awful yeah I mean comp just wants to do
um yeah it also wants to do this okay
and says this is about equal
yeah I don't know maybe if I play more
precisely I can I can uh get get to
something that resembles equality but uh
I need to play really really more
precisely than
maybe um I know and this is maybe an
idea like this could be an idea yeah
Knight to D6 and then B5 H yeah that's
better yeah this is this is not that
terrible if we consider
this yeah now I have chances to get in
get in this this type of counterplay
that's not so
bad in the game it got uh it got bad
quickly
yeah maybe maybe uh again this is an
idea it's just a very bad structure yeah
just a very bad
structure well okay can be glad that he
uh was going for the draw thanks for
watching